Therefore,
we have discussed a number of measures
reflected in 10
we will announce at this time.
First measure,
export liberalization
with expedited procedures.
This implies that
with the signing of agreements
where is guaranteed
to the domestic market,
exports are free
eh of the products that previously
had to make a lengthy process of
eh internal financing certificate
at a fair price.
Then this is already released and
has all the space and scenarios for
continue to export
abundantly and massively.
The second measure is a
the immediate expulsion of the CD inx,
upon delivery of foreign currency for exports.
This too is going to be an process,
quickly,
to the extent that exporters can
bring their foreign currency into the country
and certify
through
certain eh documents
that foreign currency has actually been delivered
in the national financial system.
This delivery of eh was immediate in cdms.
will not take more than 15 days.
The third measure is the issuance of bonds.
of Bolivia's central bank in dollars,
which is going to be a
process that will
to have an offer structured on terms and rates that
will be announced in due course these days.
and that it will obviously be worked on with the sector
private National
and with the bench eh
of the Bolivian financial system.
Fourth point,
diesel auction
to large buyers.
There will be an auction scheme
so that those
large buyers can offer
certain purchase lots of
fuel,
especially diesel,
this is intended for diesel
specifically
and that they can have delivery in their places
productive products by Io pgb.
Therefore,
what this auction will also allow is
reduce the subsidy granted by 10
this important basic measure in terms of the fact that
sectors such as the agricultural sector,
the mining sector,
the transport sector
can
go to this auction and according to your requirements.
to be able to offer
the purchase of large lots so that they can
obtain the same
at their production points
and delivered by ypfb.
The 5th measure is agility
in diesel imports for private companies
intended for self-con,
not
this standard,
this measure
is already in force in the country,
but what is
eh,
it is required to streamline the procedures.
in terms of time
and processes
and then the National Government commits itself
to generate an agility scheme in terms of deadlines,
processes and times
for diesel import permits
by companies
for public consumption.
6th measure,
promotion of private investment
for the construction of biodiesel plants
law 10 98 establishes that the private
can eh build
biodiesel plants
and an incentive scenario is being generated for
that they can eh
to undertake or carry out this type of undertaking
and she is also going to require that a
eh analysis together with ypfb
for purchase
of is from this biodiesel that will be able to be
acquired by ypfb
or that it will also go for self-con.
of those who can eh
have its biodiesel plant.
Can be 1 1 eh
establishment
farmer who wants to start his biodiesel plant
for its partners,
as they may do so in those terms.
In this way,
we also encourage
increased biodiesel production in the country
and also in this way we replace
imports.
The 7th measure is to promote investments to improve
the performance of the agricultural sector.
As we had already pointed out,
the National Government
has already been implementing programs where we have
found
in the field,
as mentioned above,
the increase in performance
per hectare in certain crops,
specifically yellow,
that we have achieved with a methodology
eh of precision farming,
to achieve quadruple
yields,
for example in paradise
and in the same way also
it is possible to do so in soy and other crops,
therefore
the productive development bank as a bank
technical assistance support to the productive sector
will be there at the forefront for
and financing
all types of ventures
who want to use this technology
precision farming,
which,
as I have already told you,
is not a fantasy.
but it is a reality.
It has generated and generates substantial increases
in productivity.
Obviously,
the development bank also
productive will implement specific programs
to provide resources
as Credit for productive capital
and for other types of productivity improvements
on agricultural properties.
September 9,
establish
tax incentives
for the purchase of Flex vehicles
and electric vehicles.
For this purpose,
the National Government
will implement measures
eh to give tax incentives
to the importation of these vehicles
Flex and electric vehicles.
To date,
there are incentives for vehicles
electrics that eh do not pay
Attention in tariff nor the i.
C.
Then we will employ
similar measures for Flex vehicles
and other tax measures
to encourage
the purchase of this type of vehicle.
And obviously this goes hand in hand with the largest production
of,
because the National Government already 29 December
has established a broader mix
aluminum with gasoline
10 to 12%.
This also makes it possible for several
aluminum producers,
especially in the
sugarcane and sugar mills,
can also establish a program of
and better crops and yields
wider to produce both sugar and iron,
but in the same way
there will be another type of venture
that allow to have the supply
and in the case of vehicles
electric also already pfb will already be
implementing a massive program of
of charging of this type of electric vehicles
in places of consumption
and mass suicide.
10th measure,
we are going to establish a band in the collection of commissions
for transfers and transfers abroad,
in such a way that it is possible to
with the other Measures,
converge
gradually to normalize
this type of charges
and in the economic agreement
productive business that the national government claims
and in Bolivian business.
The national government jointly
the business sector
will work continuously on implementation,
evaluation
and design of these and other measures to achieve
results that benefit the national economy,
caring for stability
country's economy